let's talk about bitcoin here's what
happened with bitcoin
visa will offer a credit card that
rewards purchases in bitcoin
rather than cash or airline miles in
early 2021 interesting
visa that is a level of credibility for
bitcoin like never before
for visa to say i'm going to reward
purchases in bitcoin
we're excited to add credit cards to our
suite of products and expand bitcoins
accessibility to a broader set of
consumers zach prince said the ceo
this card makes it simple and risk-free
for people to gain or increase exposure
to
new asset classes without changing their
spending or investing capital visa will
launch a credit card
that rewards users in bitcoin instead of
traditional cash error miles in 2021 the
card comes out with an annual fee of 200
users will receive one and a half
percent of their purchases back in
bitcoin and bonus of 250
in world's most popular digital currency
after spending three thousand dollars or
more within the first three months
what does this mean for bitcoin let me
jump in real quick i know this is your
wheelhouse i'll take my quick
perspective and turn it over to you guys
i
i have a phrase stay in your lane i like
to use that phrase so i'm not gonna try
to be an expert in bitcoin but i'll tell
you the one thing that caught my eye on
this thing
i think there's a lot of people out
there guys and adam you probably know
this
that want to act like they think they
know about bitcoin right and i think
visa is capitalizing on these people
because i think they think it's cool
it's going to impress people yeah i got
the credit card with bitcoin
and it's all about that 200 yearly fee
if you start doing the math on 200 times
100 000
or 300 000 people that want that card
because they think
they're they're understanding
cryptocurrency and they're into the
bitcoin game that's a lot of money for
visa that's my thought
yeah good point um you know i've
interviewed a lot of people
especially when i started my show um
to tom's point well you know they just
want to be cool because they got bitcoin
so i would ask them do you have a 401k
nope you know are you invested in the
stock market nope do you hold any gold
or any do you own any assets nope do you
have bitcoin
hell yeah i got some bitcoin it's like
i'm not sure why you gave them a country
accent
but they said they had bitcoin and you
know i said this before i'll say it
again
if you want to throw five ten you know
five ten even twenty percent of your net
worth into bitcoin if you're
in a of your asset cool give it a shot
that should not be a hundred percent of
your foundation however i will say
where we where what have we seen in
bitcoin this year it was at
rocket you know um at bottom lows at
9000 earlier this year
now it's up to 19 000 and change it's
approaching 20 000 which is
i think it reached in you know december
of 2017
uh it's if anything is happening with
bitcoin
it's being legitimized when visa comes
out and does this
paypal a few months ago said that it
would buy hold sell
bitcoin now so i think for people that
um thought the death of bitcoin was
coming i think they were wrong
however i you know there's still people
think that bitcoin is the end-all be-all
i'm not in that camp yet so but it's
looking good for bitcoin is my
point i think this is more than looking
good for bitcoin i think this is
uh uh this is visa
mainstream yeah you kidding me for visa
to say we're gonna paint bitcoin if
anybody out there is a bitcoin person i
would be screaming this off the top of
my lungs they're probably screaming
they are i'm kidding bitcoin's gonna be
going to fifty thousand dollars it's
gonna go to a hundred thousand dollars
you gotta get in you gotta you know
all that stuff that they're gonna try to
be a question for you go for it for both
of us do you think bitcoin is more
likely to go to fifty thousand
or zero oh fifty thousand it ain't going
to zero
yeah it's not going to but the
alternative is you should ask the
question a different way
is it more likely go to fifty thousand
or five thousand that's a different
cause i would say five thousand at that
point can i
make that i say zero because if i had
said fifty thousand no one would
remember that
but if by some chance i get lucky and it
goes to zero people think i'm an expert
tom you are a provocateur you and james
you're in a different provocateur right
there
[Music]